يتم نقل أكثر من 80 بالمائة من التجارة العالمية
عن طريق البحر، ويتم شحن حوالي ثلثها
في حاويات
تقع شمال مدينة
جدة، ثاني أكبر مدينة في المملكة العربية السعودية. تتمتع موانئ الملك عبد الله
بموقع استراتيجي في أحد أكثر
ممرات الشحن ازدحامًا في العالم، البحر
الأحمر، الممر الملاحي.  تمثل
أكثر من 10 في المائة من التجارة العالمية.
بدأ التقرير عملياته في عام 2013، حيث
تعامل مع مليون حاوية
بعد مرور ما يقرب من عقد من الزمن، وهو يعالج ما
يقرب من 15 مليون حاوية على الرغم من
اضطرابات سلسلة التوريد في النقل البحري،
كنت أفكر للتو في الوباء
وكيف طرق التجارة  لقد انقلبت رأسًا على عقب، فأنت تعلم أن
بعض الطرق تم إغلاقها تمامًا
ويمكن الوصول إليها، هل أدى ذلك إلى تغيير
الأشياء بالنسبة لك خلال الوباء وكيف
غيّرت السرية حقًا الطريقة التي نتاجر بها
تمامًا
وتذكر أن تلك كانت فترة من الوقت
لم تكن فيها خطوط الشحن تعرف أي منها
الموانئ التي يمكنهم الذهاب إليها والتي كانت
تعمل بكامل طاقتها أو بكامل طاقتها،
ولم يتم إغلاقها، ولم نغلقها على
الإطلاق، لذا الفضل للفرق هنا،
ومشغلي المحطات،
والكيانات الحكومية، والمنظمون الذين جلسوا بالفعل
وعقدوا ورش عمل حية حول كيفية القيام بذلك
يمكن أن تستمر العمليات
طوال فترة الوباء
أثناء الوباء، قام الميناء بتكثيف
العمليات في أحدث تقارير البنك الدولي، وقد
وصل الميناء إلى قائمة أفضل 20
ميناء إلى جانب خمسة موانئ أخرى في
المنطقة، عرف جاي أن الرؤساء التنفيذيين يشرعون اليوم
في استراتيجية طموحة  للنمو بشكل
أكبر،
يريد الجميع أن يكونوا الأفضل، لذا
يمكنك أن ترى من النافذة هنا
البحر الأحمر، لذا فهو
ممر رئيسي لتجارة الشحن بالنسبة للاقتصاد العالمي
والنقطة الأولى لكونك الأكثر
كفاءة هي أن الأمر يتطلب فقط  من 15 إلى 20
دقيقة للوصول من البحر الأحمر إلى
الولادة في الميناء، وهذا أمر
فعال للغاية، لذلك عندما تصل السفينة في النهاية
إلى الميناء، يتم
التعامل معها بكفاءة عالية، لذلك من الناحية
اللوجستية والجغرافية، فهي
تناسبك كما تعلم من هذا
الجانب ولكن بعد ذلك  لا يزال يتعين عليك جعل
الأرقام تعمل من تلك النقطة فصاعدًا،
لذا أخبرني كيف فعلت ذلك، لذلك
عندما تسافر إلى وجهة ما، ستذهب في كثير من الأحيان
إلى ميناء رئيسي
في صالة العبور ثم تحصل على
رحلة متصلة إلى
الوجهة النهائية و  تعمل شركة الشحن العالمية بهذا الشكل إلى حد ما،
لذا فإن خطوط الشحن الكبيرة
والسفن الأكبر في العالم والتي
ستحمل ما يقرب من
23000 حاوية، يبلغ طول هذه السفن 400
متر بحجم
مبنى إمباير ستيت، وهي سفن ضخمة
تأتي  هنا،
ويأتون إلى الميناء ويقومون
بتفريغ الحاويات
التي يتم تحميلها بعد ذلك على سفينة أخرى
للوصول إلى الوجهة النهائية، لذا تقوم
خطوط الشحن بإحضار الحاويات
إلى الميناء هنا والتي قد تكون
متجهة إلى أفريقيا وبلدان أخرى في
الشرق الأوسط والهند وجزر المحيط الهندي
هذا  هي منطقة
يوجد بها حوالي 400 مليون
مستهلك